okay today I'm going to talk to you
about a topic in b1 called
classification now classification is
when biologists well they basically
classify organisms into groups based on
how closely related they are to one
another and the first and most broad
classification they do is there's
different kingdoms and there are five
different kingdoms first one we're going
to look at is plants now plants are
referred to as autotrophs this means
that they can make their own food
whenever we see the word troph in
science we know it's something to do
with food and also this little prefix
here means for yourself which means they
can make food for themselves now how
they do this is they contain an
organelle called chloroplasts now
chloroplasts have this pigment in called
chlorophyll which can absorb the energy
light energy from the Sun and create
their own glucose their own food so also
all of these plants in this particular
Kingdom they all have cell walls on
their individual cells these cell walls
provide them with structure and support
the second Kingdom that we need to know
about probably the most well known one
is animals now animals
unlike plants are unable to make their
own food so we call them heterotrophs
meaning they need to get their food from
another thing another place now they're
different from plants on a cellular
level because first of all they do not
contain a cell wall instead a lot of
animals have a skeletal structure to
provide them with structure opposed to
cell walls on a cellular level also on a
cellular level animal cells do not have
chloroplasts to not have chloroplasts
which means they rely on eating other
things in order to get their energy both
plants and animals are both described as
being
multi-cellular this means that many many
cells multi meaning many many cells make
up each organism
now the third multicellular Kingdom that
we need to know about is funghi so
examples of this would be from mushrooms
toad stores that kind of thing okay so
fungi are also multicellular which means
they're made up of many many cells we
also describe fungi as being SAP for our
fights now what this word here means is
they feed of dead and decaying organisms
lovely stuff
they are similar to plants in on a
cellular level because they do have cell
walls however they do not contain
chloroplasts so they can't
photosynthesize they are not autotrophs
so on to the next one we need to also
know about this particular kingdom here
which is so I'll use a different color
which is prokaryotes now prokaryotes are
unicellular rather than multicellular
this means unique means one so this
means that they are single-celled
organisms the most classic examples are
bacterial cells so they don't have a
nucleus this is how they're really
different from a couple of these other
ones they don't contain a nucleus at all
instead they just have this chromosome
with DNA and a little ring of plasmid
DNA so that's our prokaryotes the final
Kingdom that we need to know about and
the most difficult one to spell is the
protists and it's spelt like this
so protists are also unicellular which
means that they are single-celled
organisms so I just realized that
misspelt unicellular they're
single-celled organisms as well they do
have a nucleus though so these ones are
different from our bacteria are
prokaryotes because protists do contain
a nucleus so when we're first
classifying an organism we look at see
which traits it has and as a result it
can be put into one of these different
categories as long as we know the
different features of these different
categories we can place that organism
the only other example we need to know
about a viruses now viruses are a little
bit unusual because they don't have any
of these characteristic or folk they
don't have all of these characteristics
which make up these other living things
some viruses aren't really classified as
living things so just to summarize the
five different kingdoms are plants
animals fungi prokaryotes and protists
this is the way to classify different
organisms based on different different
features of each organism thank you